bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo rétrospective et perspective sur
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine
bonjour que tu as un bon jour michael et
les temps forts cette semaine françois
hollande qui était sur tous les fronts à
la radio le matin pour détailler les
réformes à venir avec syndicats et
patrons l'après-midi pour la conférence
sociale c'était le lundi puis à la
courneuve ou n'a été élu le président de
la république qui peinent à rétablir le
dialogue
à l'assemblée la bataille du budget se
poursuit les députés ont voté la
première partie de la loi de finances
qui prévoit des baisses d'impôts il
examine maintenant le budget de la
sécurité sociale
et puis nous reviendrons sur une
proposition de loi qui impose aux
sociétés l'air un devoir de vigilance
par rapport à leurs sous-traitants
initiative
deux ans après le drame de dhaka au
bangladesh qui avait fait plus de 1000
morts dont les ouvriers textiles pour
commenter toute cette actualité avec
nous notre invité pierre laurent bonjour
ou jour sénateur de paris un responsable
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
on a appris en ce vendredi un accident
absolument effroyable
la nation est en deuil il ya eu un
accident entre un camion et un car il ya
eu plus de quarante morts
c'est pas la première fois que ça arrive
en france simplement on sent que
l'émotion aujourd'hui elle est de plus
en plus forte sur ce sur ce drame qui
est arrivé en france
bien sûr c'est un accident qui ne s'est
pas la première fois mais c'est quand
même un accident exceptionnel d'une
telle gravité je crois qu'il faut
remonter à plus 30 ans l'accident de
bonnes donc on ne connaît pas encore
précisément les circonstances de
l'accident et les raisons pour
lesquelles les deux véhicules se sont
embrasés immédiatement quand ils se sont
entrechoquées mais évidemment à ce
moment là toutes nos pensées vont aux
familles des victimes et aux s'incline
devant avec solidarité et je pense que
la nation toute entière évidemment
solidaire dans cet instant de ces
familles et il faut adresser tout de
suite
aussi les mots de solidarité à toutes
les personnels de secours
les pompiers les médecins les policiers
qui sont sur place et qui font le
meilleur pour essayer de deux
d'éclaircir d'élucider les raisons de ce
drame car n'est pas du tout question
n'est certain dpt comme noël mamère qui
vient de gironde souligné le fait
qu'avec la loi macro et y aurait de plus
en plus d'autocar sur les routes
qu'est ce qui est on peut se dire qu'il
ya aussi une question peut-être
d'infrastructures c'est une telle hausse
avec un transport routier est dangereux
et singulièrement le transport routier
de marchandises et je crois que ça fera
probablement des parties des questions
qu'il faudra à nouveau posée on devrait
on a les moyens de réduire le transport
routier par marchandise au profit du
fret ferroviaire est malheureusement en
france comme en europe ont fait
exactement le contraire tout c'est
toutes ces dernières années en mettant
de plus en plus de camions je suis
moi-même en ile-de-france très
préoccupés des risques d'accident mairie
ensuite bien sûr la circulation
excessive de deux camions de
marchandises sur les routes est
accidentogène et et c'est un sujet de
préoccupation mais il faut avant poser
toutes ces questions sur d'abord mon
s'incliner devant les victimes de
l'accident bien entendu parlera vous
connaissez le rythme de l'émission m'a
d'abord regarder un portrait qui est
dressé par vos collègues parlementaires
et puis on va revenir après pour en
discuter en s'auto proclame pas leader
il tient sa place en tant que
responsable du parti communiste et c'est
une vraie utilité de l'avoir au sein du
groupe c'est un dirigeant communiste
très respectable et en tout cas qui est
un homme de conviction c'est à dire que
ce qu'il porte comme secrétaire
nationale du parti communiste français
mais tu portes aussi comme sénateur bye
bye le porte aussi comme tête de liste
aux élections régionales je trouve qu'il
manque un peu de
peu de charisme pour porter les messages
qui sont les siens et il faudrait qu'il
s'affirme un peu plus qui se débarrasse
de gens comme mélenchon pour porter haut
et clair les couleurs de son parti et
ses idées hier laurent dépense beaucoup
d'énergie et montre beaucoup de
compétences dans ce combat difficile
c'est l'homme y les combats c'est
l'homme qui est capable de s'investir
sur des sujets très fort et de manière
en plus tout à fait pertinente et donc
oui je pense que c'est l'homme de la
situation pour redresser la gauche
aujourd'hui il n'a de cesse de répéter
dans l'hémicycle à chaque fois qu'il
prend la parole effectivement combien
les points de vue qui peuvent être les
siens sont différents de la politique et
conduit par les gouvernements en plutôt
sympathique quand même comme portrait
même si on voit l'image de philippe
dallier à l'instant tous les
antagonismes qui a aujourd'hui entre ça
c'est sûr je suis pas fier je ne suis
pas trop d'accord d'accord avec nos
positions aujourd'hui qui position ferme
par rapport au gouvernement qui est
encore tenable
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle est elle est
plus que jamais nécessaire parce que
c'est la politique menée par le
gouvernement à des soit totalement ceux
qui ont voulu la gauche au pouvoir et
surtout elle ne produit aucun aucun
résultat pour le pays le chômage
augmente la désindustrialisation un
compte rendu et le rampeau pour être
très clair c'est que vous arrivez dans
certaines régions dans certains
départements aujourd'hui à gouverner
ensemble avec cette gauche mais qu'au
niveau national c'est impossible quand
même et là il est là il nous le faisons
là nous faisons plan local nous sommes
obligés aujourd'hui pour protéger les
budgets publics nous essayons mettre en
oeuvre de nous battre contre les
logiques d'austérité du gouvernement et
pas seulement nous mais y compris des
élus locaux de cette majorité 7 à
brossard appel appelle le gouvernement à
changer de cap sur sur les questions
budgétaires il ya des départements qui
viennent de lancer un cri d'alarmé parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus payer
saab le rsa et ils sont en situation de
faillite donc ça n'est pas une question
posée par les communistes et tous les
élus locaux qui sont en butte aux
politiques d'austérité aujourd'hui alors
on va revenir au plan national avec une
semaine qui commence tambour bas
pour le chef de l'état françois hollande
invité pour une interview à la radio
puis devant les partenaires sociaux
françois hollande était partout les avec
une mission numéro un des quatre
relancer un dialogue social en mauvais
point il a visé notamment sans la citer
la cgt qui a pratiqué la politique de la
chaise vide c'était lundi cette
conférence elle nous place
elle nous place tous les présents comme
les actions devant nos responsabilités
voulons-nous une démocratie organisée et
apaisée avec des acteurs prêts au
compromis
quand ils sont possibles ou alors
considérons nous qu'il faut en finir
avec les partenaires sociaux
il est également co bode pour d'autres
de ne jamais s'engager à signer le
moindre accord en espérant d'ailleurs
que d'autres le feront à leur place tout
en dénonçant dans le même mouvement les
insuffisances du dialogue social alors
la cgt des états là est ce digne d'un
syndicat qui représente quand même un
peu de monde de ne pratiquer la
politique de la chaise le dialogue
social la cgt une pratique pas la
politique de la chaise vide elle est là
dans de très nombreuses négociations
elle a marqué son désaccord pourquoi
parce que par exemple un très grand
nombre de conflits sociaux france porte
sur la question des salaires ça fait des
mois et des mois que la cgt dit puisque
nous faisons régulièrement une
conférence sociale il faut inscrire la
question des salaires faire un état des
lieux en france s'est refusée par le
gouvernement alors c'est un dialogue
social dans lequel le medef et le
gouvernement sont les sols a fixé à
fixer l'ordre du jour d'été tu es
d'accord la cftc étaient plutôt pour la
cfe cgc
oui il ya des syndicats discutent il ya
des syndicats qui accepte de le faire
sans obtenir d'ailleurs de résultats
tangibles dans l'intérêt des salariés
et il y en a d'autres qui ont marqué qui
ont marqué leur désaccord mais ce qui
m'étonne sur la conférence socialement
c'est que depuis le début de la semaine
tout le monde parle de l'intervention
limin
r du président de la république mais
personne ne parle de l'intervention de
conclusion manuel valls or ce grand
dialogue social il s'est terminé par une
intervention de manuel valls qui a dit
eh bien maintenant dans trois mois il
faudra avoir réformé le dialogue social
donc nous allons on nous parle de
dialogue social mais la seule conclusion
tangible de cette conférence
prétendument sociale ça va être de faire
reculer encore les droits des salariés
dans les trois mois à venir et ça
étonnamment c'est sur l'autre contre il
ya un grand silence sur les conclusions
le discours de conclusion manuel valls
sur le contrat travail pour vous faites
allusion qu'on comptera sur le contrat
de travail et sur toutes les les droits
des salariés dans les entreprises on est
en phase de recul successifs et on donne
libre cours aux politiques des
actionnaires alors on fait des grands
discours sur le dialogue social mais la
réalité est exactement inverse vous vous
dites c'est que manuel valls dans son
discours de conclusion il a fait quoi il
a cassé ce qui pouvait rester du
dialogue social il a il a annoncé
clairement que la seule feuille de route
du gouvernement n'était absolument pas
le dialogue social
c'était qu'on allait mettre en cause le
code du travail et surtout il a annoncé
qu'on allait le faire dans un calendrier
incroyable puisqu'il dit fawcett mis
d'accord avant la fin de l'année
absolument sur scène en janvier pour une
loi en janvier
c'est à dire qu'une fois de plus après
la nuit après la loi macro après tout ce
qui se passe on va à marche forcée vers
une vers un nouveau projet
gouvernemental qui va satisfaire le
medef et qui ne fera non seulement pas
avec quel dialogue social qui va faire
reculer les droits des salles et vous
vous dites non vous vous appelez à
amplifier le mouvement de la
contestation sociale
c'est une menace sérieuse parce que
farid ramassage est là comment comment
est ce qu'on fait pour sa performance
comment vraiment où les gens parce que
il suffit d'aller sur les marchés suffit
d'aller discuter avec les salariés comme
je le fais moi quotidiennement que ça
donne quoi dans la campagne et bien les
gens disent mais quand est ce que ça va
s'arrêter
voilà quand est ce que tout ça va
s'arrêter quand est ce qu'on va nous
écouter quand est ce qu'on va respecter
nos nos urgences sociales et qu'on va
réellement les traiter donc il faut
effectivement pour ça dans les urnes
j'ai dit dans les urnes aux élections
régionales et dans les mobilisations
sociales amplifier la contestation de
cette politique absolument pour en
proposer une autre parce que nous ne
sommes pas des partisans du tout au rien
pourront proposer une autre et nous
avons des propositions claires sur un
plan plus politique au hamas il ya unité
de la gauche et un referundum à la fin
de la semaine ont fait le point avec
thibault le floch c'est un pari gagné
l'unité a de la dynamique avec 90 % de
votants approuvant l'union du parti
socialistes et des écologistes dès le
premier tour des régionales le pari de
jean christophe cambadélis est
effectivement gagné plus de deux cent
cinquante mille personnes ont participé
à ce référendum sur internet mais
également dans les urnes comme sur cette
place de marché à malakoff dans les
hauts-de-seine
sans unité pas déçu ses ports aux clics
et sans union point de salut pour la
gauche ce n'est pas l'avis de tous les
écologistes c'est une élection à deux
tours
au premier tour on choisit au deuxième
tour on élimine c'est ce qui est dit
traditionnellement je pense que
justement si les gens qui sont sensibles
à l'écologie est la qualité de vie en
ile-de-france voté au premier tour
écologistes donné un gros poids
l'écologie ça permettra un rassemblement
de deuxième tour plus dynamique plus
efficace une ligne désormais difficile à
défendre selon les députés socialistes
selon eux la victoire du oui au
référendum oblige des écologistes ce que
nous demandent les électeurs de gauche
c'est d'arrêter cette espèce de repli
sur soi cette espèce de disputes
permanente entre appareils
les socialistes se réuniront rue de
solférino pour établir un programme
commun axé sur une dizaine de mesures
applicables dans toutes les régions ils
vous obligent se réfère à damas quelque
chose à quoi que ce soit mais d'abord il
n'y a pas eu de référendum
une opération communication du parti
socialiste sur internet principalement
dont personne ne maîtrise les résultats
et qui nous dit que le parti socialisme
des listes uniques au premier tour
autour de lui ça n'est pas le cas dans
les 13 régions il y a des listes que
nous conduisons et que nous allons
conduire jean conduis moi même une en
ile de france
nous faisons des propositions très
claires et ce dont nous avons besoin aux
élections régionales c'est simple c'est
de politique
gauche audacieuses dont les régions les
régions s'occupent de sujets très
importants les logements où lé transport
voit la fin des belles politique
fodé baro d'evel politique sociale pour
ça donc nous nous portons des
propositions les socialistes vont
emporter d'autres mais pour les mettre
en oeuvre pour les mettre en oeuvre
il faudra affronter les politiques
d'austérité du gouvernement
rien si tout le monde répond si tout le
monde répond dans le même sens et si les
électeurs accompagne à travers les
propositions gauche et bien et bien nous
verrons mais pour le moment moi je
conduis une liste par exemple qui dit
dans la région ile de france
encadrement des loyers en ile-de-france
soutien aux mères qui veulent construire
du logement social et pas seulement du
logement social mais aussi de
l'accession sociale à la propriété mise
en cause
application de la loi sru c'est à dire
mis en cause des villes dont ne veulent
pas très bien moi je vais regarder ce
qu'il ya dans le programme de claude
bartolone je verrai ce que disent les
électeurs ce que je dis aux électeurs
c'est que si vous voulez la mise en
oeuvre de ces mesures là par exemple
l'encadrement des loyers dans toute
l'île de france
eh bien il vaut mieux le faire avec une
liste de gauche qui est conséquente
puisque nous nous avons défendu cette
position plan national plutôt qu'avec
une liste socialiste au premier tour qui
nous dit faut le faire dans la région
mais on peut pas le faire honneur
national avec le gouvernement donc se
donner des garanties pour obtenir
l'encadrement des loyers dans toute
l'île de france c'est mettre le plus
authentique l'alliance que je conduis
vous avez vu les scores en tout cas que
vos billets un sondage dans la presse
quotidienne régionale qui donne le front
national très très haut notamment dans
le dans le nord 46 % pour gagner deux
régions et on se dit là maintenant
pourquoi est ce que vous ne faites pas
cause commune avec le temps les
socialistes coûté lise mois joseph la
mort
je ne fais pas une règle agne électorale
avec des sondages donc j'ai un programme
allégé aimerait qu'on organise le débat
public elle débat médiatique autour des
propositions des uns et des autres ou
pas autour de chantage dans lesquels on
discute jamais des propositions qui dit
par exemple que loïc qui dit par exemple
que le leader du front national en ile
de france a fait un regret monique et
affaires communiqué dans lequel il dit
qu'il ya 7 milliards de dépenses
publiques a supprimé
les régions un milliard et demi en ile
de france propose de geler de supprimer
purement et simplement en ile de france
le budget de la culture le budget en
direction des associations de jeunesse
le budget en direction des quartiers
prioritaires le budget en direction du
logement social qui parle de ça tout le
monde nous dit bon moi je veux qu'on
organise un débat transparent sur ces
questions et qu'on voit qu'il a
réellement vous politique là un débat là
est bien sûr je demande l'égalité de
temps de parole dans la période de
campagne électorale ont fait leur
affaire en piste et nous en sommes à des
années lumières à des années lumière
puisque là c'est le grand cirque du
tripartisme et et en plus avec une prime
media sync conseil national temps de
parole officielle
pardon la semaine prochaine le temps de
parler mais ça peut ça peut commencer
maintenant puisque alors on est on est
tous en campagne donc il faut que les
arbitres étaient avec nous parce que je
n'ai pas le cas en attendant la campagne
les députés travail puisqu'ils ont
débattu cette semaine
il continue à débattre du budget 2016
l'assemblée nationale a d'abord voté le
premier volet de la loi de finances pour
2016 la partie recettes 2 millions
d'euros de baisses d'impôts sont prévues
pour certains ménages
c'est la mesure phare de ce budget et
les députés ont dans la foulée examiner
les quais le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale arrive dans l'hémicycle
dans une version peu modifié en
commission
seuls 21 mandement sur 398 ont été
adoptés parmi les mesures phares la
maîtrise des dépenses de l'assurance
maladie mais aussi la généralisation des
complémentaires santé depuis le 1er
janvier l'employeur à l'obligation d'en
proposer une à tous ses salariés
plusieurs amendements visant à préciser
la mise en oeuvre de cette mesure ont
été adoptés le gouvernement veut
l'étendre
je pense en particulier aux salariés en
contrat à durée déterminée très courts
ou aux salariés qui travaillent
simultanément chez plusieurs employeurs
le principe d'une couverture
complémentaire attaché à un employeur
leur est en théorie applicable mais dans
la pratique inapplicable concrètement
l'employeur versera à ses salariés une
aide individuelle destinée à faciliter
l'acquisition d'une complémentaire santé
la deuxième étape du pacte de
responsabilité sera par ailleurs mise en
oeuvre avec une baisse des cotisations
sociales mais elle sera décalée dans le
temps en raison de l'adoption de
nouvelles mesures pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises
je pense aux sur amortissements des
investissements je pense aux correction
des effets de seuil je pense également
mesures en faveur de l'apprentissage et
conduiront des dépenses de plus d'un
milliard d'euros en 2016 pour le budget
de l'état et donc ses mesures de
réduction des cotisations du pacte
seront réalisés à partir du 1er avril
prochain
enfin au programme de ce budget 2016 le
renforcement de l'accès des mineures à
la contraception est une garantie contre
les pensions alimentaires impayées ainsi
qu'une enveloppe de 40 millions pour
développer les soins palliatifs
enfin des amendements sur le prix du
tabac seront débattues dans l'hémicycle
il ya beaucoup de choses dans ce budget
de la sécurité sociale et notamment une
protection maladie universelle pour tous
ça c'est un progrès c'est une vraie
mesure de gauche sinon la
caractéristique générale du budget c'est
la réduction massive des dépenses de
santé
c'est ça le long bloc globale alors à
l'intérieur de ça on peut discuter mais
l'on bloque globale elle diminue
gravement au n'est pas ce qu'il ya sur
la complémentaire santé
c'est une mesure en trompe l'oeil parce
qu'en vérité qu'est ce qui se passe
la part de dépenses remboursées par la
sécurité sociale ne cesse de baisser et
l'organisation de cette baisse deux par
deux
santé remboursées obligatoire n'arrête
pas de diminuer elle atteint des niveaux
très bas sur certaines parties des soins
où est la clé on oublie eh bien on
augmente le financement de la protection
sociale et par exemple quand il a si
nous proposons une cotisation
additionnelle sur les revenus financiers
des entreprises
il ya de plus en plus de revenus
financiers des entreprises qui placent
leur argent leur trésorerie
singulièrement les plus grosses et bien
sûr ses revenus financiers qui sont
maintenant très important
l'aic les les employeurs ne payent rien
eh bien nous nous demandons tout
simplement que ses revenus financiers
cotisent au même niveau que ceux du
travail ça rapporte plusieurs dizaines
de milliards par an et cette mesure là
elle est refusée par évidemment par la
droite
oui qui poussent des hauts cris qu'on de
telles mesures mais aussi parce que
c'est possible qu'ils disaient non
qu'ils aient pour quitter pour une autre
politique
même sur le budget 2016 ils ont quand
même baissé elle revoit on les y en a
certains qui se sont abstenus mais pas
ses notables aurait pu voter contre
pouria amirshahi a voté contre et je le
salue mais effectivement je le redis je
leur dis que leurs protestations contre
l'orientation budgétaire ne peut pas
rester dans cette demi-mesure et moi ça
fait des mois que je les invite à
joindre leur voix aux nôtres pour exiger
un autre budget que celui là qui est
informé peut-être un petit groupe 1 à
par l'assemblée nationale c'est possible
ça il y à vous savez il y à des députés
qui maintenant travail avec le nôtre qui
sont dans d'autres groupes à l'assemblée
nationale par exemple dans le débat
budgétaire
la semaine dernière des amendements ont
été cosigné par les députés de notre
groupe mais aussi par des députés
d'autres groupes alors ça n'avance pas à
la vitesse où personnellement je le
souhaiterais mais ce travail là nous
allons le continuer parce que la seule
personne ifa regret dit la seule
perspective crédible dans cette
situation et bien c'est de construire le
rassemblement de toute la gauche anti
austérité de tout ce qu'ils veulent sans
là derrière la france des politiques
d'austérité
on pourra revenir un petit peu au sénat
s'était les questions d'actualité au
mardi c'est un petit peu nouveau il ya
un droit de réponse un droit de réplique
c'est souvent un moment propice à des
échanges un peu musclé écouter cet
échange entre christiane taubira et un
sénateur du front national
ma question madame la ministre est
simple quand votre politique pénale
défendre at elle enfin les victimes et
non les bourreaux camp mais très douce
sans remise de peine pour tous
quand les parquets se soucier se
soucieront du bien commun plutôt que
d'appliquer votre idéologie libertaire
ou d'attaqués sur vos ordres
vos adversaires politiques bref quand
serez-vous ministre de la justice et non
de la justice nous appartenait à une
famille politique monomaniaque y passe
son temps à chercher des boucs
émissaires et paranoïaque parce que vous
voyez des envahisseurs partout je vois
bien que j'ai un rôle privilégié dans
votre entreprise de diffamation et
lorsque votre parti est attaquée est en
délicatesse en tout cas avec la justice
vous m'accuser de donner des consignes
au juge d'instruction
en fait vous ignorer la loi du 25
juillet 2013
mais surtout manifestement sévérité pour
tous et impunité pour vous on prend note
de vos réflexes votre culture et de vos
pratiques on imagine ce que ça donnerait
si vous arriviez au pouvoir mais nous
allons nous battre pour que ce soit
absolument impossible alors ne venez pas
de parler ni de laxisme ni de
complaisance vis-à-vis des voyous le
laxisme monsieur le sénateur c'est de
s'accommoder d'un leader qui combine à
la fois les condamnations multiples et
les responsabilités politiques le
laxisme c'est de ne pas condamner la
violence dans vos manifestations ou en
marge
walt est des journalistes ou attaques
des personnes et les jette dans la seine
même au sénat climat tendu on sent même
que dans la société ce climat est tendu
oui il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
beaucoup n'y a pas beaucoup de violence
comme monde il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
beaucoup de tensions sociales
il ya beaucoup de gens aux oies sépare
la situation et on comprend parce que
les politiques qui sont menées pour le
moment n'offrent aucun espoir d'avenir
et donc il ya beaucoup de gens qui
voudraient que la france change de cap
et retrouve le cadre de la solidarité et
le cap social
on a certes elle elle est à dîner dans
la presse disait ce week-end que la
situation prête à exploser ce que vous
partagez
il ya un climat où l'on sandro sont
partout il ya un climat explosif et les
gens surtout les gens ne ne supporte pas
que d'être face à un mur c'est à dire
ils posent des questions et ils ont
l'impression qu'ils sont toujours face à
des gens qui ignorent les questions à la
rose
qu'ils veulent se faire respecter et je
pense que c'est profondément c'est une
exigence profondément démocratique se
faire respecter et beaucoup trop de gens
l'impression qu'ils ne le sont pas à
lamia l'entreprise ni dans la vie
publique nationale
françois hollande lui ne s'est pas
forcément faire respecter non plus il a
été hué à la courneuve l'un des théâtres
des violences de 2005 en banlieue cette
visite visait à donner le signal de la
lutte contre les discriminations
apporter des promesses d'emplois mais il
a donc été hué par des habitants et
aussi apparemment
comme le révèle le comme l'a révélé
cette semaine le parisien par des
militants parti communiste est ce que
vous étiez au courant mais qui coûtait
c'est quand même incroyable jusqu'à en
quoi le fait de démettre une
protestation contre la politique
gouvernementale est un manque de respect
dans cette ville à la courneuve 72 % des
gens voter françois hollande en 2012
72% des gens et qu'est ce qu'ils ont à
l'arrivée ils ont une politique plus
antisociale que jamais la gauche a dans
la donne dans l'île et bien sûr que non
françois hollande france allant dé la
direction actuelle du gouvernement a
effectivement tourné le dos aux
habitants de ces banlieues et bien il
lui on voit là ils lui ont signifié
mais vous savez il suffit d'aller
discuter sur un marché il suffit d'aller
discuter à la porte d'une entreprise
faut rencontrer ce genre de réaction il
n'y a pas besoin de deux caméras
moi je vais tous les jours sur les
marchés il ya des gens qui nous le
disent très simplement parfois avec de
l'émotion parfois en colère parfois plus
calmement mais ce climat là qui est le
résultat de la politique actuelle est
bien là rsa l'habilitent elles ont un
congrès vézien l'exécutif vous avez dit
récemment que françois hollande ne
pouvait plus être le candidat de la
gauche qui serait mêlé à même d'être le
candidat de la gauche
et bien il y a beaucoup de travail pour
y parvenir parce que moi je pense qu'il
faudra une bonne candidature je pense qu
mais ça justement je pense que le moment
n'est pas de trouver le nom le moment
c'est de dire à toutes les forces qui
veulent autre chose que la candidature
de françois hollande parce qu'elle va
mener la gauche dont le mieux en cette
candidature à coup sûr et chacun le voit
bien il n'y a pas besoin d'être un génie
de la politique et pour savoir que si
ces six et sept soldats
et bien tard il faut donc des
écologistes et socialistes les gens du
front de gauche et la gauche sociale et
politique
mais moi mais moins parmi les autres et
bien il faut que nous trouvions les
moyens d'un travail commun pour faire un
nouveau projet de gauche et que nous
fassions émerger une candidature commune
si nous sommes capables de le faire nous
allons aller au devant d'une attente qui
est celle de millions de francs quand le
nom n'ont pas encore le nom mais peu
importe
tout le monde croit qui compte commencer
par le nom et bien moi je dis c'est
exactement l'inversé qu'il faut faire il
faut commencer par le projet de gauche
le définir tous ensemble et on trouvera
le repas allez encore une fois de
l'économie et du projet de loi macron
trois mois après son adoption mais au
parlement on regarde de très près ce qui
se passe sur cette loi
seulement 11 décrets d'application ont
été publiés aux usa avec elisa
bartholomé eloi fleuve de 308 articles
trois mois après son adoption par le
parlement la loi macron peine être
totalement appliquée pour l'instant
seuls 11 décret sur les 95 nécessaires
ont été publiés où en est on parmi les
décrets déjà signé la libéralisation du
transport par autocar ou l'extension du
travail le dimanche dans les zones
touristiques internationales de mesures
emblématiques de la loi mais l'objectif
de 80% des décrets publiés avant la fin
de l'année reste encore loin
pourquoi ces rotors car certaine mesure
nécessite la signature de plusieurs
ministères par exemple les décrets sur
les professions réglementées dépend à la
fois de bercy et de la justice grille
tarifaire nouvelles conditions
d'installation la mise au point de ces
questions prend du temps mais d'ici la
publication des décrets ces professions
estime être dans les clous
il est évident que l'âge est restreint j
restreint mais mon embauche un bien
évidemment en attendant ses écrits ses
décrets je ne vais pas embaucher c'est
trop périlleux je vais pas mettre en
péril
l'instrument de travail tant que je ne
suis pas donc je suis je ne serai pas
informé de ces décrets d'ici les
prochains mois
le gouvernement espère mettre en
application le plus grand nombre de
dispositions parmi elles la
libéralisation des professions
réglementées bien sur l'assouplissement
du permis
ou encore la réforme des prud'hommes il
y avait tellement de choses dans ce
texte que ça devient très compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre
vous êtes plutôt content ouvre ta vous
dites c'est dommage mais moi je me suis
battu contre cette loi et je me battrai
contre sa mise en application
vous savez je vous prends un exemple
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
avec le travail du dimanche à paris on a
des limites et des zones touristiques
internationales
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
en ce moment le premier effet c'est que
les spéculateurs se ruent dans ces zones
touristiques internationales dans ces
périmètres et vont proposer à des petits
commerçants de déménager en rachetant
leur fonds de commerce tout de suite
parce que il espère que le foncier va
exploser dans ces zones là donc le
premier résultat de ce soi disant très
gros projet m'a concept entrants
si on ne maîtrise pas la situation est
heureusement la ville de paris se
mobilisent contre ça c'est de faire
exploser le prix du foncier spéculatifs
en ile de france
mais en termes de création d'emplois
personne n'a jamais démarré que le
travail d'une gauche créé d'emplois non
non il ya même une étude commandée par
la ville de paris qui a montré l'exact
contraire et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que la ville de paris s'opposait à dans
son entier la majorité municipale à ce
qu'a décidé le gouvernement en allemagne
gagner conséquent même pardon pour
certains s'alarment et gagner un petit
peu plus et que la réalité c'est que les
salaires sont très très bas dans le
commerce et qu'on fait du chantage comme
on fait du chantage à l'emploi de re
certain nombre d'entreprises chère
france et ailleurs aux salariés là on
fait du chantage aux salaires et on leur
dit la seule manière de gagner un petit
peu plus alors que les gens n'arrivent
plus à vivre avec mon salaire c'est
d'aller travailler le dimanche
donc c'est du chantage aux salaires mais
ça n'est en aucun cas de ces c'est pas
une augmentation des salaires c'est
qu'on oblige les gens à a bousillé leur
vie familiale pour gagner pour gagner
quelques euros de plus alors on n'a pas
fini de reparler de la loma crouch
puisque seuls 11 décrets d'application
sur 95 ont été publiés on en reparlera
mais je vous propose de passer à
mercredi
avec ces images aériennes qui ont fait
le tour des télévisions celle de la
jungle de calais
et bernard cazeneuve s'est rendu sur
place il a annoncé de nouvelles mesures
d'urgence humanitaire ainsi que des
renforts sécuritaires écouter aucun
migrant ne doit se retrouver sans
solution de mise à l'abri si les
températures hivernales mettre sa vie en
danger
afin de répondre aux besoins des femmes
et des enfants et de les mettre à l'abri
j'ai décidé de doubler le nombre de
places du centre d'hébergement qui leur
est réservé les équipements
correspondants seront construits d'ici à
la fin de l'année et dans l'intervalle
des tentes chauffées seront montés par
la sécurité civile
dès la fin de cette semaine comme je
l'aï indiqué hier à paris et j'en prends
l'engagement ici à calais aucune femme
aucun enfant ne demeurera privées d'abri
dans cette ville kalhoro présent jim
jarrassé notre partenaire du scan vous
interroger dans quelques minutes mais
katia vous interroge d'avoir sur calais
est sûre notamment cette décision de la
maire de calais natacha bouchart des
républicains qui a demandé à bernard
cazeneuve une intervention de l'armée
face à une situation devenue ingérable
et ce qu'elle a raison mais
l'intervention de l'armée règlerait quel
problème
quels problèmes maintien de l'ordre oui
mais quelle est la situation
c'est une situation qui n'est absolument
pas facile à régler c'est le résultat de
la guerre ou donc on devrait
s'interroger sur les politiques qui ont
plongé dans le chaos et qui continuent
de plonger dans le chaos tout le grand
moyen-orient et ça ça et là a dit oui
mais si si ça dépend de la france parce
que la france allait engagés
militairement en libye en syrie en irak
donc la france a une responsabilité dans
cette situation au même titre que
d'autres puissances occidentales
deuxièmement deuxième cause de cette
situation le mur qui existent la
fermeture des frontières d'accord parce
que les les gens qui sont là n'est
s'agglutinent à cet endroit là parce que
la frontière à la et annick et fermes
ayant calé six états du mur hongrie mais
nous avons un mur au front ce mur là
c'est le farm la ferme au niveau de la
veille qui a brillé de caledon prier en
discussion aux variantes
excusez moi il
q sion avoir entre la france et la
grande bretagne sur cette situation sont
des cons et troisièmement dit que m et
troisièmement nous avons effectivement
face à cette situation humanitaire
catastrophique qui concerne l'ensemble
de l'europe nous avons je pense un
devoir humanitaire et évidemment il ne
faut pas laisser les gens dans cette
situation donc il ya un travail
compliqué à mener c'est vrai qu'il est
compliqué pour pouvoir accueillir sur
l'ensemble du territoire européen et
national
les familles non pas en les concentrant
dans des camps ou dans des ghettos de
cette nature et encore moins dans les
conditions indiquées leçons mais pour
qu'il réussisse progressivement à
s'intégrer l'agenda des deux pays
bien sûr c'est une si c'est une zone qui
est aujourd'hui une zone de très
difficile à vivre pour les personnes qui
sont d'abord on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
de bagarres beaucoup de trafic sur place
de trafiquants qui viennent faire leur
marché
parfois d'ailleurs des trafics mêmes
humains des trafics de prostitution mais
aussi d'autres trafics
heureusement qu'il y à des associations
qui mène avec courage du travail sur
place à la mais évidemment il faut
l'aide de la puissance publique je
voudrais interrogé sur une autre
proposition de loi qui a été examiné au
sénat
elle impose un devoir de vigilance pour
les entreprises face à leurs
sous-traitants
cette décision a été prise deux ans
après l'effondrement d'un immeuble au
bangladesh qui avait causé la mort de
plus de mille ouvriers du textile et
dans les décombres avait retrouvé des
étiquettes de marque de la grande
distribution française notamment
est ce que vous pensez bien laurent que
la loi peut vraiment régler ce qui
relève d'un code de bonne conduite
international annonce et je pense que la
loi peut être agissante et
malheureusement nous ne faisons là ce
qui a été voté que voter est une mesure
est un paramètre aux problèmes un par
rapport aux blessés un parc en tout cas
c'est ça met le doigt sur un vrai
problème et mais je pense qu'on peut
faire beaucoup mieux par exemple il faut
réduire considérablement le niveau de
sous traitants ça veut dire quoi quand
une entreprise sous traite elle peut
sous traiter une fois puis cette sous
traitance ou très puis même etc etc
il ya parfois sept ou huit niveaux de
sous traitance et donc on ne sait plus
en vérité et c'est vrai pour des marchés
publics
et bien par exemple il ya une mesure
comprendre c'est que dans les marchés
publics il faut interdire plus de trois
niveaux de sous traitance deux ou trois
niveaux de sous c'est une proposition et
d'europe
oui c'est une proposition que nous avons
déjà porté il faut interdire plus de
deux ou trois niveaux de sous traitance
parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait de la
transparence deuxièmement il faut
responsabiliser y compris pénalement et
financièrement les donneurs d'ordre
parce que les donneurs d'ordre ne
peuvent pas dire ah bah nous on savait
pas donc il faut et les donneurs d'ordre
ce sont les grands groupes
il faut qu'ils soient responsabilisées
devant cette situation et troisième en
europe
il faut changer la directive des
travailleurs détachés qui organise en
fait ce type de système qui ne le combat
pas qu'ils organisent et tout le monde
sait que dans le bâtiment et dans la
restauration par exemple dans l'est dans
les grands chantiers français on utilise
le travail détachées et souvent c'est du
travail dissimulé pour organiser le
dumping social
et là encore les grands groupes sur les
premières responsables de ça le poids
est fait sur cette situation va passer
au jeudi avec un débat très médiatisé
très politique mais qui est annulé
invité à débattre dans une émission
politique sur france 2 marine le pen a
finalement décidé d'annuler sa venue à
la dernière minute la chaîne a
déprogrammé l'émission
après plusieurs jours de polémique
pierre laurent marine le pen peut-être
tout se permettre
visiblement elle se croit en tout cas
elle croit qu'elle peut le faire elle
vient de jouer hier sa star on trajet ce
que marine le pen victime des médias ça
fait rigoler tout le monde quand même vu
le temps d'antenne qui est le sien non
c'est le grand cirque du tripartisme et
alors les uns se disputent pendant que
l'hélice par exemple comme les nôtres
sont totalement écartés de d'énormément
de débats ou des temps d'antenne à qui
se met en place la chef d'orchestre de
la mascarade puisqu'elle a parlé de manu
katché marine le pen elle même mais
malheureusement elle a des premiers
violons extrêmement active dans son
orchestre au premier rang desquels les
chaînes comme monsieur pujadas qui a
déjà invité c'était la cinquième invite
invitation marine le pen par david
pujadas vous ne l'aviez jada mais bien
sûr et surtout avait après la
justification qu'il a donné dans le
nouvel obs en disant qu' elle était la
seule personne d'envergure nationale et
que ça justifiait le nombre
d'invitations et depuis quand c'est à
david pujadas de décider à la place des
électeurs et à la place de ce qui se
passe dans la vie politique nationale
qui a le droit et qui est d'envergure
nationale qui a donné ce pouvoir à david
pujadas
de quel droit s'arroge le service public
de 200 il ya des pertes que ça je suis
désolé mais par exemple le parti
communiste qui a qui a deux groupes
parlementaires qui est qu'il ya des
milliers d'élus locaux qui continuent de
jouer un rôle important dans la vie
politique nationale n'a jamais été
invité à cette émission pas une fois pas
deux fois pas trois fois jamais matin
j'étais invité une fois à cette émission
dans un plateau où il y avait quatre
invité dans une émission mais sol pour
pour occuper ce dernier avait attiré
désir que ça prendrait voix référé
irréprochable pardon france télé est un
terreau cham sur cet événement
non seul mais évidemment pas puisque
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que l'émission
a été constaté a été contestée parce que
c'était la énième invitation est donc ça
a soulevé des protestations mais le
problème c'est qu'on tournant parce
qu'au bout du compte je comme je le dis
c'est le grand cirque du tripartisme
c'est à dire maintenant la droite le
front national
il part qui socialisent cers à se
partager tout le temps d'antenne et bien
il ya d'autres forces politiques et il
faut briser ça et je répète mon âge on
réclame dans la période que nous
rentrons
égalité de traitement entre les listes
on annonce aux élections régime alors
pierre laurent on va en reparler mais
cette fois avec notre partenaire du scan
qui nous a rejoint jim jarrassé tout de
suite c'est la loupe du scan
avant de parler de reparler de marine le
pen le dossier air france avait
également le dossier air france le
comité central d'entreprise s'est réuni
hier a confirmé la suppression de 1000
postes pour l'année 2016 est ce que la
france est en train de mourir car le
rend la politique qui est menée par le
gouvernement et par là qui est
actionnaire l'état est actionnaire d'air
france et par la direction d'air france
et ses actionnaires
mais la compagnie dans une très grande
difficulté ou et si nous continuons avec
les saignées d'emploi successifs parce
que je rappelle qu'air france a déjà
supprimé plus de 10000 emplois que là il
y en a au moins encore trois ou quatre
mille sur la sellette et que déjà alors
qu'on a room et même pas en neuf ça on
lit qu'il en faudra peut-être d'autres
donc ce sont les politiques actuellement
menées qui sont en train de saigner la
compagnie est fière moi j'étais avec les
salariés déjà présents elle devant le ce
lieu très sécurisé il y à il y a une
chose a souligné contrairement à ce qu'a
dit le gouvernement à ce qu'a répété
manuel valls à deux reprises dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'ils essayent
d'opposer les catégories de personnel
entre entre elles hier il y avait
l'intersyndicale dont tout le monde
était là
les personnels au sol les personnels
navigants et les pilotes que le dire ils
sont tous unis pour refuser le plan
actuel donc ça n'est pas ce n'est pas en
nous posant les catégories de personnel
ils posent tous la même question qui est
la question de l'avenir de l'entreprise
et il ya d'autre choix à faire cette
semaine vous avez annoncé votre tête de
liste pour les régionales en île de
france
parmi elles julie morel qui est agent au
sol à air france à l'instar des tests de
tête de liste dans le val d'oise
elle fait partie du cce qui s'est réuni
hier
est ce que vous aviez prévu de
l'investir avant l'explosion de la crise
air france
il ya quelques ce que nous avions prévu
dès le début dès la constitution de la
lys et de faire de cette liste une liste
où nous nous ouvrions plus de 30% des
candidatures à des candidatures ici du
mouvement social associatif etc etc
c'est le cas la lys
nous allons déposer officiellement le 2
novembre comportera 30 % de salariés
nous avons fait une conférence de presse
avec une vingtaine d'entre eux l'autre
jour il ya donc des salariés tous les
secteurs et donc sur air france faisait
partie faisait partie des entreprises où
nous avions demandé à des à ddd salariés
investi dans le conflit 2 et ça avant
avant les événements du 5 octobre
je vous signale parce que ça n'intéresse
pas les médias mais que j'étais à roissy
le 23 septembre pour une initiative avec
les salariés à l'invitation
d'organisations syndicales pour parler
en l'occurrence journée du 5 octobre
vous l'utilisez politiquement on a vu
éclore sur internet des visuels qui sont
diffusées par le front de gauche
notamment un visuel avec une chemise
patron à découper soi même qui est une
référence évidente à la chemise du drh
da france les même faits des clips vidéo
est ce que vous n'avez pas un peu
l'impression de d'exploiter
politiquement véhicules et social ces il
nous nous exprimons sur sur ce conflit
comme absolument l'ensemble des
transactions de biens légitimes je
rappelle les assurances visuels de
coignières france est le premier
employeur privé en ile de france
moi je conduis une liste en île de
france et bien effectivement l'avenir
d'air france avec deux grandes zones
aéroportuaires dans la région ça
m'intéresse et un emploi à air france
ces 4 ou 5 1 points et induit donc c'est
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
de familles qui sont concernées par
l'avenir d'air france donc que cette
question là soit au coeur de ce que nous
portons avec l'autisme notre lycée
diderot minutes sur la campagne des
régionales sur la campagne des
régionales
vous savez qu'il faut atteindre 10%
pouvoir se maintenir au second tour est
ce que vous y croyez ce que vous pensez
que vous allez pouvoir atteindre cette
légende symbolique jeu je travaille pour
ça évidemment si si je conduis une liste
avec l'ambition même de présider la
région si c'est possible c'est parce que
nous avons des idées en matière de
transport de logement de rééquilibrage
d'emploi de développement économique de
lutte contre la pollution
nous avons un programme qui est
parfaitement crédible nous avons occupé
des responsabilités dans la région donc
effectivement moi je travaille à mettre
cette liste le plus haut possible si
vous
les 10% vous allez vous maintenir face à
claude bartolone qui a priori les
obtiendra aussi mais écoutez moi dans la
région il n'y a pas que c'est pas un
face à face à face à moins que les
autres lits se retire c'est pas en face
à face entre claude bartolone et pierre
leroux
il ya d'autres listes à ma connaissance
donc moi je veux battre le front
national et la droite dans cette région
vous savez je suis conseiller régional
et valérie pécresse les terres restent
donc dans dans la région je l' ai
toujours eu en face de moi chaque fois
que j'ai proposé une mesure sociale
valérie pécresse l'a combattaient alors
je vais pas la laisser dans la région de
la fin donc moi je veut effectivement
travailler à une victoire de gauche mais
pour les politiques de gauche offensive
et je compte pour ça sur le fait que ma
liste arrive le plus haut possible et si
possible en tête
et bien merci pierre-laurent d'avoir été
notre avis merci de gym et non se
retrouve michael la semaine prochaine
très bonne ces deux programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
ouah